sapete che differenza c'è tra una rapa e
una barbabietola certo sono due radici
ma quando il mio banco del mercato
mi chiedono due rate io prendo due app e
non due barbabietole il problema è che
99 su 100 il cliente intendeva 2 verrà
bietole che chiama rape rosse perché non
ne conosce la differenza è come se uno
entrando un negozio di animali chiedesse
un cane ma nella sua testa immaginasse
un gatto è un piccolo aneddoto questo
per raccontarvi come io mi sia accorta
che stiamo perdendo la conoscenza
profonda del cibo di cui ci nutriamo non
conosciamo più gli ingredienti a tal
punto che alcune specie alcuni vegetali
non li mangiamo proprio più proprio
perché non li conosciamo da questa mia
riflessione si alimenta ogni giorno la
mia idea
la mia idea è quella di dare una nuova
opportunità economica alla mia azienda
agricola che si trova in strada
carpaneda è una campagna qui alle porte
della città in un terreno che è
minacciato sempre di più dall'avanzare
della cementificazione e del brutto che
è stato coltivato per anni con la
monocoltura tipica delle nostre campagne
mais su mais e con molta chimica
io oggi non spero che il mio terreno
venga trasformato in capannoni che
diventi edificabile non lo coltivo più
chimicamente much coltiva ogni anno
migliaia di specie vegetali con tecniche
biologiche
per offrire a quanti vogliano come me
del buon cibo prodotti freschi in un
ambiente agrario che io voglio riportare
alla bellezza che aveva 40 anni fa
spesso mi chiedono da dove nasca questa
mia idea sicuramente la mia idea nasce
dalla mia storia nasce dall'amore che ho
io e alla mia famiglia per il terreno di
strada carpaneda nasce dalla mia idea di
essere io la protagonista di un
cambiamento nasce anche dall'idea di
creare da me stessa il mio lavoro io
ricordo carpaneda i miei primi ricordi
sono quelle di 40 anni fa quando i miei
genitori si innamorarono di questo pezzo
di terra che acquistarono e dove
costruirono la nostra casa
da quel momento la nostra casa i nostri
campi sono il centro delle nostre vite
di quando ero bambina ho tantissimi
ricordi e sono tutti legati alla terra
ricordo le passeggiate nei campi le
corse a rincorrerci nei campi di mais
con le canne più alte di noi dove ci
rifugiamo perché nessuno ci cercasse
ricordo i primi bucaneve che spuntavano
i fossi i salti che facevamo per andare
a prendere le fragoline di bosco quel
profumo dell'erba appena sfalciata che
da bambini ci facevano raffreddare tutti
i pomeriggi d'estate
ricordo le passeggiate facevamo per
andare alla chiesa di san lazzaro quando
ancora il quartiere dei pomari era un
aperta campagna e arrivavi dietro la
chiesa c'era ancora la fattoria
ecco i miei ricordi sono tutti legati
alla terra
gli anni sono passati ho iniziato gli
studi mi sono iscritta al liceo dopo
liceo scientifico
ho scelto ho scelto di studiare agraria
a quel tempo
tutti mi chiedevano me lo chiedono
tuttora chiara come mai hai scelto di
studiare agraria in fondo la mia non era
una famiglia di agricoltori a casa mia
tutti erano appassionati in un certo
senso avevano
il sangue verde scorreva una passione
verde nella vita di ognuno dei miei
familiari
ma la mia non era una famiglia contadina
di vocazione infatti quando studiavo
all'università io mi sentivo spesso un
pesce fuor d'acqua
si parlava di molti argomenti che non mi
interessavano di rese di barche di mais
di soia quasi mi annoiavo mi sembrava un
po vecchio quello che mi stavano
insegnando i professori ripensandoci
sono in due esami preso il massimo dei
voti furono orticoltura e botanica
sistematica non ci fu certo un caso se
ci penso oggi alla mia strada non mi era
per niente chiara fu sabato pomeriggio
un incontro fortuito
io ho sempre avuto la passione per le
arti manuali per lavorare con le mani un
sabato pomeriggio in scrissi ad un corso
per rintracciare i salici che una di
quelle artiche stiamo perdendo legate
alla terra
questo corso si teneva in una scuola
speciale era una scuola in cui stavano
avviando un'attività di educazione
ambientale e in questa scuola stavano
cercando delle figure che affiancassero
i bambini dell'attività pomeridiane
quando mi conobbero mi scelsero sono
passati 15 anni da quel momento e da
quel momento mi sono sempre occupata di
di orti scolastici un'attività che ho
creato inventato insieme ai tanti
bambini che ho conosciuto e con loro ho
capito quanto oggi i bambini non abbiano
più la possibilità di camminare a piedi
nudi nei campi o di infangarsi come
facevo io da piccola ma ne abbiano un
gran desiderio
ho potuto constatare come questi bambini
non mangino più nessun tipo di verdura
nei di frutta spesso perché anche i
genitori non gliela propongono più ma se
la fai coltivare bambini e nell'orto
allora sì che è davvero buona
non immaginate neanche come un bambino
possa divorare un'insalata un ravanello
l'ha coltivata lui e l'ha appena
raccolta quasi ancora sporca di terra da
quanto ne è fiero sono dieci anni poi
che io sono diventata anche madre e
quando diventi genitore ti interroghi o
almeno così ho fatto io diciamo ti
interroghi veramente su questo senso la
diciamo che faccio una breve parentesi
non credo che siamo di genitori che
stanno a fare questa esperienza e questo
è il mio primogenito francesco e quando
diventi genitore almeno questo è stato
il mio percorso ti interroghi veramente
su che cosa posso fare io per la vita
dei miei figli cosa posso fare per
migliorare quale cibo
voglio dare da mangiare ai miei bambini
quale cibo voglio dare io che cosa posso
fare anche per i miei amici per quelli
che conosco ed è stato lì che mi è
scattata l'idea del lavoro che faccio
adesso quindi la mia idea dei 100 orti
ho iniziato quindi a coltivare non più
solo per insegnare ai bambini non più
solo per me nel mio orticello di casa
non più solo per sperimentare ma
iniziato a coltivare per tutti quelli
che vogliono condividere con me questa
idea questi date coltivare sano
quest'idea di coltivare il diverso
oggi io nella mia azienda coltiva ogni
anno più di mille varietà di ortaggi
diverse vedete questa foto è molto bella
molto significativa molti sono ortaggi
tipici del nostro passato molti voli
sono anche ortaggi tipici di altre
colture alimentari perché nella
contaminazione c'è molta ricchezza di
molti ottengo le sementi autoproduco le
piantine ogni anno la colazione più
caratteristica della mia azienda è
quella sicuramente dei pomodori o più di
400 semi di varietà diverse di pomodori
a ogni anno l'esperimento almeno 200 nel
mio campo oggi
questo lavoro è la mia vita non potrei
sicuramente più farne a meno lavoro lo
vedete è molto duro devi fare molta
fatica
ci sono molti pesi da sollevare fa
sempre o troppo caldo o troppo freddo
poi piove ci sono mille sfide da
affrontare la natura ti mette sempre
alla prova ma se sai andare con lei più
a seconda anche molto e ti dà veramente
tantissima energia tantissime emozioni
come vi dicevo nella mia azienda coltivo
tantissime cose strane ma anche se gli
ortaggi sono più consueti come può
essere una carota o una barbabietola mi
sono accorta che le persone davvero non
sanno più come utilizzare queste materie
prime per questo ho iniziato anche a
tenere dei corsi dove
insegno alle persone appunto come
utilizzare questi prodotti ottenuto un
incontro qualche settimana fa ed è stato
molto divertente e stato un esperimento
per me ho fatto fare una degustazione
alla cieca ad alcune signore gli ortaggi
mi sono molto impegnata a cercare il
sapore più incredibili che la natura
possa offrire quindi delle piante
provenienti da parte tante parti del
mondo foglie piccanti foglie 12 foglie
ruvide sapete qual è la pianta che ha
riscontrato il maggior
interesse da parte dei partecipanti a
questa pianta
molti di voi forse la conosceranno si
chiama portulaca oleracea è un
infestante tipica delle nostre campagne
e d'estate è un airbus che viene
normalmente diserbate riservata dai più
da chi non ha più occhi per cogliere la
bontà e la semplicità che la natura ci
offre
grazie